I suspect like many people in this room
I fell in love with the beats at college
I can remember going to the campus
bookstore and seeking out the poetry
aisle in the Ginsberg collections which
felt to me like a lifeline I mean I was
an undergraduate a closeted kid from New
Jersey who wanted to be a creative
writer and I mean Allen Ginsberg was
meant the world to me I mean he was just
he's openness and his honesty just it
felt to me like a transmission from the
person I wanted to be when you start to
get into the beats you can only you
can't just do a little bit and there are
a lot of biographies out there and this
murder appears as a footnote in many of
them this murder was front-page news in
the New York Times in 1944 so knowing
that and knowing that these three
amazing most beloved writers of the 20th
century were involved in this murder it
just seemed to me kind of the only
mystery was why it hadn't been tackled
before dramatically so that's when I
went to John who is my college roommate
and I suggested that I told him I wanted
to write it as a nonfiction book and
John do you want to tell them about the
Jedi mind trick that you pulled on my
brain Austin came to me with the idea of
doing this as a piece potentially a
fiction ten years ago I had just
finished film school done a couple of
shorts and Austin was beginning to get
some renown as a short story writer and
a playwright and as he's telling me the
story that he wants to tell I of course
thing start seeing the movie in the back
of my head and I decided to convince him
that I don't know if it would work as a
short story but as a movie it would be
amazing but what was really poignant
about this is then I asked him if we
could collaborate and work on it
together and you know we've been friends
since we were 18 years old and we've
shared you know all of our work up until
that point
Austin's actually the first short film I
ever made on super 8 before I really
knew what I was doing I showed it to
Austin and he said to me John it doesn't
stink and it's much better than I
thought it was going to be but that was
exactly the encouragement I needed at
that time to keep going and in terms of
do we do it as a crime drama I mean we
knew we had an event and we had this
event you know the story that nobody
really knew but yet was the thing that
caused Allen Ginsberg Jack Kerouac and
William
to stop talking about art and what they
wanted to do to change the world as
college students and to really put pen
to page and become writers and start
their revolution who we realized you
know the character with the greatest arc
over the course of the story was Allen
Ginsberg because he starts off at the
top of the movie a dutiful son who takes
care of his emotionally ill mother whose
father is a struggling poet and he knows
he has a voice inside and he's scared
you doesn't want to disappoint his
father and say maybe I want to do this
and do this in my own way and then of
course he meets this beautiful and
charismatic young man who is somewhat
also emotionally ill are troubled and
again in a way becomes his caretaker but
by the end of the story you know it's a
classic story I think we've all been
through this of learning to take care of
yourself and find your own voice and
that idea a movie about someone our
favorite you know one of our favorite
authors finding their own voice Daniel
let me let's follow up with that and
tell us what resonated for you when you
read this script I mean you're you're
from England and you're playing one of
America you know American literature's
and poetry's American icons now in
Ginsberg I think one of the things that
I love about it it's just and the thing
that jumps out at you about the script
is the fact that it the story is
constantly being moved along but it's
never becomes just expositional it's
always moved along through exchanges
based on character and relationships and
that's always the mark of I think very
good writing Ginsburg's nationality much
like his sexuality or his religion don't
really weren't things that I
particularly focused on and intimidated
by just because like I knew that he's
American so I'll do both find the accent
I'll work on the accident I'll you know
get that and and and but really the
things excited me about the character
was that when you read his Diaries as a
teenager he was just a really really was
unusual and interesting and and and and
a character you know worth putting on
film regardless of his later fame you
know he was he's interesting enough of
his you know standing alone at this
point and you know it's that really it's
the split then John it's something John
and I have talked about a lot with a lot
of creative people operate on this
system kind of veering between poles of
anxiety and ambition and and you know
that's what Allen was as a teenager he
was both desperately insecure on some
level and then very shy socially but
also incredibly bright it had a men
confidence in his in his intellect and I
think that it's the sort of the gap
between those two things is where really
every interesting character kind of lies
and and trying to you know reconcile
those two things John worked with me in
a way that I've never been worked with
before and and put time in with me that
you know due to the nature of the jobs
that I've done hasn't been necessarily
time and and and John for the year that
I was doing how to succeed before we did
kill your darlings John and I would meet
at least sort of once a month and this
started going through the script going
through scenes while yes in what I was
doing how to take yeah so we did some
Sunday and then we just do like yeah we
just go through you know work on
accident physicality and because that's
the other thing about and he's wasn't
athletic at all I track but he had a
really interesting physicality and he
was of you if you have the time or
inclination to watch pull my Daisy the
exam a very there are film they made
he's kind of goofy and fun and and he's
actually that's the other thing I liked
about it was that he was fun like he by
all accounts he was really good company
and and and I think you you can kind of
like well he was like he was a laugh
he's you know he sounds like he was kind
of funny and silly and and I think it's
very one of the things I love about the
movie is the fact it is fun it's not
just a sort of history lesson you know
it because I think if you make a film
about the beats who were having a great
time and it's not fun then you've sort
of missed the mark really I think this
script actually does a really good job
of accurately capturing who Lucian was
as a person but also if you do go back
and look at Ginsburg's Diaries and the
correspondence between Ginsberg and
Kerouac and that kind of thing you can
start to pull up stories of things
Lucian did that I think are really good
keys into who he is as a person
stuff like standing on the dock of a
ship and sinking it just so we could
feel what it was like to be on a sinking
ship or like you know going to a
restaurant and ordering the most
expensive steak raw just so we could
take it and throw it into the waiters
space like drinking wine at a bar and
chew
off the glass and chewing the glass in
his mouth just to like get a reaction
from people around him you know like
these kinds of things that actually you
can find and are written if you dig I
you know I think are just more proof
that in the script it's fairly
accurately portrayed who he was at this
point in his life you know originally
when Austin and I were writing the
script we realized we had a murder story
set in 1944 and I looked to see actually
what had won Best Picture in 1944 and it
was Billy Wilder's Double Indemnity
Laura Gilda it was a high point for
American film noir and I thought well
why not incorporate the actual texture
and structure of the films of the 40's
within the film itself so that's why we
started the film off in the jail cell at
this heightened point of tension and
then flashback to more innocent times to
see how we got there and see if the
characters can escape their fate or not
so I did heavily research into mark noir
styling but then I realized an academic
recreation of a genre that already
exists was kind of lifeless and didn't
have the kind of youth and vitality that
we wanted in this movie and then while
looking at color noir isn't seeing where
Noirs went of course the French took
there and put their hands on it and
started the new wave and I thought there
we go
now there's an arc for the camera and
Sidney Lumet's style and very classical
I went to find kind of my spine of what
I wanted the camera to be as well as you
know in every department including the
script and the movie really is about
going from places of conformity like the
University and Rose setting in row
houses in Paterson New Jersey to
nonconformity and so as you can see the
movie starts off with very strict
compositions with expressionistic
lighting that are reminiscent of noir
and then as these two young men meets
and we go down the rabbit hole with them
the camera all of a sudden comes off the
tripod and becomes a lot more handheld
and jazzier and free and it was one of
those cases where you look at the
dailies after the first couple of days
and you see the energy and the vitality
that my actors are bringing and that
reid is bringing the production designer
is bringing and you realize your child
is starting to find its own voice and I
think the biggest lesson I learned was
to step out of the way and kind of just
let the voice of the movie start
becoming who it had to be